what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and they just dropped
the trailer for The Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special and it looks
pretty fantastic the Guardians of the
Galaxy are actually heading to Earth
where Peter Quill was born and where he
was taken from when he was just a boy
right after his mother died we're gonna
go through this trailer and break it
down but first there is something that
you need to know about this holiday
special and that is that this is going
to be Canon to the MCU and you are going
to have to watch this holiday special to
know what's happening in Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 which is coming out not
too far from now next year and yes this
is confirmed by the director of this
holiday special and Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 James Gunn and of course he
directed Guardians 1 and 2. James Gunn
confirmed that this does take place
between Guardians 2 and Guardians 3 and
that this will serve as sort of the
epilogue of phase four and if you don't
know what that means that usually serves
as a comment or a conclusion to what has
happened so this is essentially going to
be the conclusion the true conclusion of
phase four because now this will
technically be the final project not
black panther wakanda forever because
this is coming out on Disney plus
November 25th and essentially what we're
going to find out in this Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special is all of the
stuff with Star-Lord and Gamora kind of
how they're addressing the fact that
Gamora is no longer with them but there
is indeed another Gamora out there now
Gamora obviously died in Avengers
Infinity War Thanos sacrificed her to
get the Soul Stone but then in Avengers
end game nebula Gamora and Thanos from
2014 along with his army came into our
universe and Gamora turned good and she
survived so she's out there somewhere so
she's out there somewhere in our
universe and if the TVA doesn't pick her
up in which there isn't really a TVA
right now not at least a normal one that
Loki had to deal with at first if they
haven't picked her up she is out there I
don't think we'll see much much of her
in this holiday special but I do believe
this will be addressed in Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 3. but you do have to
watch this holiday special to know
what's happening in Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. so let's break down this
trailer and talk about its awesomeness
now it starts off with craglin talking
about how he saw a calendar and realized
that on Earth right now it's Christmas
time there's obviously some dialogue
that they leave out of the trailer some
dialogue that we don't hear but
essentially the Guardians team is
talking about going to Earth for
Christmas in which nebula replies they
don't have time James Gunn clarified on
Twitter that the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special takes place between Thor
love and thunder and Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 not between Guardians
Volume 2 and infinity War so this is
after Thor 11 Thunder and what we
learned in Thor love and Thunders that
the Guardians of the Galaxy are going
around the Galaxy basically answering
distress calls being Heroes and saving
people so when nebula says that they
don't have time to go to Earth she is
most likely referring to the fact that
they are actually being the Guardians of
the Galaxy they're going around the
Galaxy answering distress calls saving
people so nebula says they don't have
time to go but mantis says that Peter
has been so depressed lately it might be
a good idea to go to Earth to his home
planet to celebrate one of his holidays
that he believes in to cheer him up so
they decide to go they go to Earth to
celebrate Christmas they land in L.A on
the Hollywood sign it's a little bit
meta here a little bit sarcastic because
obviously La is where they film
everything they go to Hollywood
Boulevard which is where the premiere
for all of the movies are held including
the Guardians movies Infinity War
Avengers endgame all of the movies that
they've been in the premieres are held
right there and we see Drax and mantis
on Hollywood Boulevard people are
looking at them staring now this could
be for a couple of different reasons one
it could be because they're obviously
not from the planet Earth now people
aren't freaking out because at this
point in time the people of Earth have
been through so much they've been
through Thanos his snap the Hulk
snapping everybody back they've been
through all of the events from every
Avengers film Thor and all of them are
heroes and their very well known which
could be another reason why people are
looking at them the Guardians of the
Galaxy did help save the universe and
they were on Earth during Avengers end
game and they did all fight with the
Avengers so people might know who they
are they might be kind of famous we did
just learn from the Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania trailer that Ant-Man is
famous we know that Wanda was so famous
that she was on a lunchbox so perhaps
the Guardians are a little bit famous
here as well so maybe some people know
them but I think primarily people are
just kind of freaked out to see mantis
and Drax who are basically aliens to
them at this point in time the people of
Earth might not know if they're a threat
or if they're friendly but of course
they are friendly they are here just for
Peter so they're trying to cheer him up
it looks like they go to some parties
some underground Raves we see them doing
a lot of Christmas stuff exchanging
gifts there are lights everywhere Peter
looks actually happy that his friends
have done this for him and notice that
we actually see an adult Groot here for
the most part he's not teenage group
anymore but he doesn't look exactly as
evolved as he looked during the first
Guardian so he's probably like a young
adult at this point now based off of the
events that play out through the rest of
this trailer it looks like they go to
Earth and try to cheer Star-Lord up a
little bit and it probably works just a
bit but he's still kind of depressed and
missing Gamora so they talk about what
ways they could cheer him up mantis says
they'll need something special that
he'll never forget but Drex says what
about some one special and they arrive
at the house of the legendary as they
say it Kevin Bacon now this is obviously
a big call back to Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 1. going back to the scene
with Gamora and Star-Lord where they are
waiting to talk to The Collector the two
of them are talking together Peter talks
about dancing and Gamora says that she
doesn't dance in which Peter says
there's a story where he comes from
about people like you called footloose
and within it a hero Kevin Bacon
Footloose is clearly one of Peter's
favorite stories he's clearly talked
about it more than once and has
mentioned Kevin Bacon more than once
because the Guardians are going to try
and kidnap him essentially to give to
Peter her as a gift to try and cheer him
up so nebula and Drax arrive at Kevin
Bacon's house he looks at them very
confused wondering what's going on on
his camera but of course Drax just bust
through the front window they tell him
he's coming with them as a Christmas
gift for their friend and it's the
actual Kevin Bacon which is hilarious
and awesome at the same time of course
he thinks he's about to be kidnapped by
essentially aliens so he tries to run
away now from here they basically tell
us the entire cast that's going to be in
the series of course it's the main
Guardians of the Galaxy cast Star-Lord
nebula craglin mantis Drax Groot rocket
and Cosmo the space dog who's going to
be voiced by Maria bakalova most people
know her from Borat but it doesn't seem
like we're gonna actually hear her talk
in this very much in the comics Cosmo
the space dog was the security chief of
the space station nowhere which we have
seen multiple times now in the MCU Cosmo
is a telepathic Soviet space dog and has
been a member of the Guardians of the
Galaxy in the comics it's unclear how
exactly Cosmo is going to be depicted
here in the MCU in the Guardians of the
Galaxy a holiday special as we see
rocket feeding Cosmo a treat now in the
comics Cosmo was a Soviet space dog and
in the 1960s he was launched into
Earth's orbit by the Soviet space
program as part of an experiment but was
actually Lost in Space eventually he
would arrive at nowhere and was said to
be mutated by cosmic rays giving the dog
telepathy and other powers it's unclear
on whether or not Cosmo will have powers
in the MCU but we'll have to wait and
see on that and that is pretty much the
trailer it looks like a very very fun
time classic Guardians humor filled with
a bunch of holiday spirit for the
holiday times there had been a rumor
going around for a while that Kevin
Bacon was going to show up and now it is
confirmed by the trailers there's also
been a rumor that the Silver Surfer
might appear in this because someone has
been listed as the surfer however it is
definitely not confirmed that the Silver
Surfer will be in this they recently
mentioned that the Silver Surfer might
be getting his own Disney plus special
presentation which I'm all here for
because these special presentations are
actually turning out quite nicely so
don't hold your breath on that I know a
lot of people have been asking about it
either way this holiday special looks
like it's going to be a very very fun
time and again you have to watch this to
know what happens in Guardians of the
Galaxy 4 or otherwise you might be a
little bit lost in the beginning so let
me know your thoughts about this trailer
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up to date on the MCU for live updates
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof